bonsoir bienvenue ravi de vous retrouver
dans Ça vous regarde ce soir un
documentaire LCP exceptionnel sur
Alexandre solgénitine bonsoir Nicolas
MTIC c'est vous qui en êtes l'auteur
avec Jean crépu le courage de la vérité
l'archipel du coulag qui sera diffusé le
24 octobre prochain sur notre antenne
c'est l'histoire d'un des manuscrits les
plus importants du 20e siècle une
véritable honte de choc à la fois
politique et idéologique et qui n'a pas
pris une ride ce manuscrit au vu de
l'actualité de la guerre de Poutine en
Ukraine on va en parler longuement tous
les deux tout à l'heure notre grand
débat ce soir faut-il faire une pause
sur l'écologie face à la crise du
logement lutte contre les passoirs
thermiques ou la bétonnisation de
nombreuses voix s'élèvent pour reporter
les contraintes environnementale la
pénurie de logement conjugué à la hausse
des taux une bombe sociale averti même
Édouard Philippe alors dans ces
conditions l'impératif climatique
peut-il attendre nous en débattons avec
mes invités dans un tout petit instant
enfin nos affranchis ce soir le parti
prix politique de Yael gouse le regard
sur l'Europe de Richard verli et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée avec Stéphanie des
pierres voilà pour le programme vous me
suivez Nicolas MTIC ça vous regarde
c'est
[Musique]
parti
c'est une crise dans la crise depuis la
hausse des taux d'intérêt la donne a
complètement changé on ne compte plus
les élus de tout bord qui alertent sur
la bombe sociale qui arrive sur le
logement dans notre pays crise de la
demande de la construction hypertension
sur les locations dans ces conditions
faut-il faire une pause sur les
contraintes environnemental comme
certains le réclam bonsoir Marjoline
mier milfer bienvenue sur ce vous êtes
député renaissance de lzer et vous êtes
la corapportrice de la mission
d'information de l'Assemblée nationale
sur la rénovation énergétiqu des
bâtiments vous avez remis votre rapport
hier vous débattez ce soir avec
Pierre-Henri Dumont bonsoir députés les
républicains du PAT Calais bonsoir
Jean-Baptiste hos bienvenue porte-parole
de l'association Droit au logement et
bonsoir Éric alouche bonsoir ravi de
vous accueillir vous êtes directeur
exécutif du réseau d'Agen immobilièrees
era ce sont près de 500 agences dans
tout le pays alors Nicolas Miletic le
logement c'est un sujet concernant
n'hésitez pas à interroger ou ou même à
intervenir dans dans ce débat on
commence par planter le décor comme
chaque soir pourquoi certains pensent
que la rénovation thermique des
bâtiments n'est plus si urgente que ça
on voit cela dans le chrono de blco
qu'on accueille tout de
suite bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir Miriam
bonsoir à toutes et tous je vous invite
à vous retourner alors ce soir on parle
de rénovation énergétique que et dans ce
sur ce sujet c'est impossible de ne pas
parler de la DPE donc tout le monde sait
ce que c'est ici peut-être pas chez vous
donc qu'est-ce que c'est que la DPE
c'est le diagnostic de performance
énergétique c'estàdire que si vous
voulez aujourd'hui vendre ou louer un
appartement c'est devenu obligatoire
donc une fois que le diagnostic est fait
votre bien est classé dans une de ces
SEP catégories de A à G donc on remarque
que les très bons élèves ceux qui sont
très bien protégés contre les fuites
énergétiques sont très peu nombreux en
revanche à l'autre bout F et G ce qu'on
appelle les passoirs thermiques ça
représente à peu près 17
% des résidences principales et donc
s'ajoute à ça un calendrier qui fait que
si vous êtes F ou G à partir de 2028 et
même dès 2025 pour le G vous ne pourrez
plus louer votre logement le problème
qui se pose par rapport à cette
réglementation c'est que assurer donc la
rénovation énergétique de 5 millions
plus de 5 millions logement euh c'est
pas si évident d'une part euh parce que
même quand les propriétaires ont les
moyens on a du mal à trouver de la main
d'œuvre il y a une vraie pénurie vous
voyez de main d'œuvre trouver des
artisans dans ce domaine si bien que euh
les l'immobilier enfin les
professionnels de l'immobilier
s'inquiètent là c'est la FNAIM donc la
Fédération de l'immobilier qui trouve
qui juge que le calendrier est intenable
on aura pas le temps de tout faire et
donc si on n' pas le temps de tout faire
ça pose un problème puisque euh FG 17 %
des logements qui ne risquent de ne plus
être à la location euh c'est déjà
beaucoup mais dans certaines régions
c'est encore plus on écoute donc la
patronne de ne City qui nous parle du
cas d'île-de-fance on s'est rendu compte
qu'en Île-de-France 46 % des logements
qui sont aujourd'hui loués dans le dans
le secteur privé sont des passoirs
thermiques donc potentiellement ces
logements risquent de sortir du marché
de la location vous imaginez que l'effet
que ça peut avoir en Île de France alors
du côté des politiques ça c'est les
professionnels il y en a un qui
s'inquiète depuis longtemps des
conséquences de cette rénovation
obligatoire des passeoirs thermiques qui
étaient prévu dans la loi climat et
résilience vous savez c'était Jean
casfex qui était à Matignon à cette
époque celui qui s'inquiète c'est son
prédécesseur c'était Édouard Philippe
qui dès le début de l'année vous voyez
disait que cette idée de rénovégation
obligatoire dépeur thermique était une
folie et il en a remis une couche à la
rentrée en disant que si on continuait à
foncer de ce côté-là on allait carrément
avoir faire à une catastrophe ou une
bombe sociale donc pour donner un
jugement si Sévre en fait il s'appuie
sur sa expérience de maire de la ville
du Havre où voilà ce qu'il a observé
j'observe que dans un certain nombre de
ces
quartiers sortir du marché de la
location des
appartements classé en G c'est
mécaniquement réduire l'offre locative
pour les plus modestes alors i la
majorité se divise un peu parce que
Édouard Philippe c'est quand même la
majorité mais même au gouvernement il y
a des voix dissonnante regardez Bruno Le
Maire il y a une semaine a dit que bon
ben il faudrait peut-être revoir le
calendri on aurait peut-être pas le
temps de construire autant de choses
d'autant que la décision a été prise en
2021 avant la hausse des taux donc
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui on aurait pas
fixé les objectifs aussi ambitieux cela
dit ça n'a duré qu'un jour puisque dès
le lendemain il a fait marche arrière
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé aller savoir
bon moi j'en déduis que à l'Élysée il y
a quelqu'un qui est bien décidé à
accélérer sur ce dossier et que donc
même Bruno Le Maire doit siifier
d'illeur il est pas le seul à vouloir
accélérer euh il y a un rapport
parlementaire qui a été publié ben hier
ou aujourd'hui on a l'une des
rapporteurs avec nous qui dit la même
chose là si on veut avancer sur ce
dossier il est urgent d'accélérer et
pour accélérer il faudrait même tripler
les aides publiques alors quand on parle
de rénovation thermique est-ce qu'il
vaut mieux reculer pour mieux sauter ou
est-ce qu'il vaut mieux sauter tout de
suite sinon bah on va faire que reculer
hein merci beaucoup c'était très très
clair avant de répondre à cette question
qui est le cœur de notre débat je
voudrais qu'on fasse un petit État
deslieux de ce qui se passe sur le
marché de l'immobilier avec vous Éric
halouche on entend qu'on ne vend pas
qu'on ne peut plus acheter qu'on ne peut
plus louer en gros que tout est bloqué -
27 % s des ventes d'appartements en un
an avec la hausse des taux d'intérêt ça
c'est CENTURY 21 Qui qui a avancé ce ce
chiffre la demande s'effondre est-ce que
vous vous décririez les choses comme une
une bombe sociale une une une véritable
crise profonde auquel on fait faceasse
maintenant alors nous avons un double
problème un problème qui est un problème
ancien qui est l'insuffisance de
production de logement en France ça
c'est pas nouveau ça c'est pas
conjoncturel c'est structurel et ensuite
on a un deuxième problème qui est celui
de l'augmentation rapide des taux de
crédit qui est spectaculaire puisqu'on a
vu une augmentation en quelques années
en 2 ans on a vu on est passé de 1 % à 4
% même un peu plus aujourd'hui parfois 5
si on inclut effectivement si on prend
le taux d'usure qui actuellement à 5,80
on est effectivement très haut alors
juste pour pour rappeler quand même le
contexte que entre 2010 et 2020 on avait
une moyenne de transaction qui était de
916000 à l'année sur 12 mois glissant
donc ça c'était la moyenne pendant ces
années on a passé le capâ du million de
vente en en 2019 en mai 2019 précisément
donc pour la première fois dans
l'histoire on a passé ce cap du million
de vente et puis on a culminé sous
leseffet de de de plein de choses et
notamment des taux de crédit qui étaient
extrêmement bas on a culminé en août
2021 à plus d'un million de 100000 et
aujourd'hui la courbe elle fait ça et
donc vous voyez ça a été très brutal
aujourd'hui sous l'effet de la baisse la
hausse des taux mécaniquement ça revient
à une situation qui devrait être normale
dans quelques temps alors on peut pas
lire dans les boules de cristal mais
effectivement actuellement les dernières
statistiques disponibles officielles
celle de juillet 2023 vous avez ét de
977000 transactions vraissemblablement
cette année on sera entre 900000 et
950000 transactions donc c'est pas un
drame le problème il est que on a un
problème de logement en France parce
qu'on a une insuffisance de logement en
France et ça c'est le problème et c'est
un problème de fond c'est un problème
qui va durer et si on s'y attellele pas
maintenant on risque d'avoir des
problèmes plus tard parce beauucp y a
une crise de la construction il y a pas
assez de de logement mais il y a aussi
les matières première qui dont le prix
augmente l'inflation le pouvoir d'achat
le budget dans un pour les Français
c'est c'est quoi c'est un bon tiers
c'est ah bah oui c'est un bon tiers mais
c'est pas seulement le ne% c'est pas
seulement la construction c'est tout
l'ensemble du logement parce
qu'aujourd'hui sur la multiplication
d'un certain nombre de contraintes les
contraintes administratives les
contraintes environnementales qui sont
réelles qui sont réelles le problème des
matières premières avec des promoteurs
qui choisissent de ne pas mettre en
place leur programme tout simplement
parce qu'ils peuvent pas tenir leur prix
on est effectivement se cumule de
problèmes ce qui fait que tout ça ça
augmente ça sacroit et on a
effectivement un problème aujourd'hui
Jean-Baptiste terou vous on connaît vos
combats à droit au logement ce sont les
jeunes les plus modestes les plus
précaires qui sont évidemment vos vos
premières source de mobilisation bombe
sociale Édouard Philippe qui dit
situation on va vivre une situation
explosive est-ce que vous le voyez sur
le terrain déjà alors d'abord il a une
responsabilité sur accrce qu'on connait
aujourd'hui monsieurir Philippe puis il
a été premier ministre faut pas
l'oublier et il a tapé dans les APL et
les aides à la construction de logements
sociaux oui effectivement on manque de
logement en France mais en manque de
logement abordable c'est de logement à
loyer abordable pour les locataires qui
sont de moins en moins riches parce que
globalement ceux qui sont les classes
moyennes ont accédé à la propriété et il
y a une popérisation fait des locataires
bon y compris dans le secteur privé
c'est c'est un élément don qu'il faut
prendre en compte donc à partir de là si
vous voulez le logement privé est plus
en plus difficile d'accès pour des
ménages qui ont des revenus plutôt en
baisse et avec quand même la hausse des
taux ça change tout alors ça c'est
l'accession je ne peuvent plus espérer
propriétaires le départ ou a des
conséquences aussi sur les location
attendez les prix de l'immobilier ont
monté à mesure que les taux d'intérêt
ont baissé c'est-à-dire que bah ouais
c'est-à-dire que les marges ont été
maintenu voir augmenté au fil des années
je pense qu'il y a eu les années d'ors
des mil d'immobilier bon et à un moment
donné quand quand quand ça peut ça peut
plus enfin quand ça se croise entre les
besoins de la population et
particulièrement de la population écire
et bon la les recettes des profits
maximum un moment donné il faut faire
des choix et pour nous il faudrait
produire aujourd'hui du logement social
voilà c'est une réponse très concrète
dans une situation de crise d'autre part
il y a des logements vacants bon alors
il faut regarder ce qui se passe de ce
côté-là mais dans les zones tendu il y
aurait lieu de les mobiliser de mener
des politiques vigoureuses de
mobilisation voilà qui qui on va venir
au on va venir aux solutions mais alors
et sur la question nous euh écologique
on est nous on reste on reste carré il
faut absolument avancer sur l'isolation
thermique je veux dire on est en danger
maintenant il faut pas reculer il faut
avancer on peut aider les plus modestes
à se loger tout en étant écolos c'est le
message de droit au logement pierrehenri
duumot dans ces conditions on a bien
compris que là on était quand même au
bord deun grosse crise et qui peut même
se transformer hein c'est se économique
très important l'immobilier mais il y a
des effets de cascade potentiel faut
ralentir le calendrier pour vous sur la
fin des passoirs thermiques ce qui est
sûr c'est que en tout cas et je rejoins
ce qui vient d'être dit en partie c'est
que le gouvernement Emmanuel Macron en
particulier n'a pas arrangé les choses
pardon mais on va reparler de la baisse
de 5 € des aPL on a l'impression que
c'est quelque chose qui est totalement
anodin 5 € d'APL ça allit directement
dans la poche des bailleurs sociaux pour
qu'ils puissent d'une part construire et
d'autre part rénover faire des économies
d'énergie isolations par l'extérieur par
exemple des bâtiments qui étaient c'éta
une connerie hein je crois que c'est
d'ord mais là on a le ministre vergrit
ministre du Logement qui vient
d'annoncer 400 millions d'euros par an
pour venir abonder les fonds de
rénovation des logements locatifs
sociaux sauf que ça fait donc sur 3 ans
1,2 milliards les économies réalisées
par les 5 € d'APL depuis le premier qu
depuis que ça a été mis en place c'est 6
Milard mais c'est 6 milliards d'euros
c'estàd qu'on a retiré 6 milliards
d'euros du logement locatif social pour
pouvoir faire les rénovations
énergétique d'une part et pouvoir bâtir
d'autre part et on leur redonne dans un
geste de grande bonté 1,2 milliards on
voit bien qu' a un tuilage non le
bil auourdui cela parce que il y a en
effet un déficit de création de
logements locatifs sociaux sur les
questions environnementales puisque
c'est votre question moi je suis
haau ça le nombre de logements locatifs
sociaux qui ne peuvent pas être sortis
parce qu'il y a des questions parce
qu'on trouve chardon au milieu d'une
prairie exemple très concret dans la
commune où je suis toujours l'élu local
il y a v projet de béguinage pour les
personnes âgées à loyer modeste on n'
pas pu le faire parce que l'adrial a
trouvé un chardon soit-disant rare pas
trop de sigles mais bah l'autorité
environnementale régionale a trouvé un
chardon rare et donc on a 30 logements
de type béguinage des petites maisons où
on mettait des personnes âgées à faible
revenu qui n'a pas pu être faite voilà
concrètement ce que ça veut dire donc je
comprends qu'il faudrait peut-être faire
une pause dans le contex faut faire un
choix non faut faire un choix faut faire
un choix entre dire soit on a d'un côté
des personnes qui ne pourront plus se
loger et qui pourront pas se loger à
loyer modeste voir des personnes qui
travaillent qui ne pourront pas trouver
de logement et je pense ici par exemple
à la fin du dispositif Pinel qui est
prévu par le gouvernement dans ce projet
loi où on a en particulier dans la
couronne d'Île-de-France des personnes
qui travaillent avec des des salaires
autour de 2000 € qui pourront plus se
loger parce qu'il n'existera plus de
logement pour ces personnes là et elles
devront se se rabattre sur des logements
indignes c'est ça la réalité de la fin
du dispositif Pinel et donc donc il y a
un choix à faire nous le choix qu'on dit
c'est que la bombe qui arrive la bombe
sociale la bombe de logement locatif qui
ne seront plus mis à disposition la
faiblesse vous avez raison de le dire du
nombre de logements présents en France
qui est structurel entraînera une
situation dramatique et que l'urgence
c'est d'abord de loger les gens bon bah
là c'est vraiment le débat fin du monde
fin du mois absolument avant la fin du
monde il y a la fin du mois absolument
et donc il faut d'abord parler de de ce
qui est la priorité du quotidien des des
Français vous l'entendez vous l'entendez
madame la députée cette petite musique
qui monte Édouard Philippe c'est votre
ancien Premier ministre c'est la
majorité Bruno Lemire est revenu dessus
mais il a dit qu'à titre personnel il
pensait que c'était pas une bonne idée
d'aller sur ce rythme là alors qu'est-ce
que vous répondez alors premièrement euh
le débat choix du monde fin du monde fin
du mois c'est un choix qui s'est posé
pendant le débat des gilets jaunes si
vous vous rappelez bien et les gilets
jaunes même ils ont dit que ils
refusaient de choisir entre les deux ils
veulent pas avoir à Cho isir entre avoir
le droit d'avoir un toit sur la tête ou
d'avoir la capacité c'est la fin de la
taxe carbone quand même les gilets Jaun
un arbitrage de non mais du coup
clairement il y a des objectifs de
mettre des moyens sur les sur les
objectifs qu'on se fixe donc ça c'est
une chose mais ils ont dit clairement
qu'ils ne voulaient pas choisir
aujourd'hui ils veulent pas avoir êre
mis dans la situation de devoir choisir
entre la peste et le
coléra avoir un toit sur la tête ou
avoir le droit de se chauffer décemment
ou d'être protégé contre les chaleurs
qui les qui les étouffent en été donc le
le cas de d'édard Philippe et la manière
dont ça s'est posé vous c'est pas tout à
fait juste puisqueen fait la loi elle a
été votée en 2019 c'est dans la loi
énergieclimat qu'on a mis en uvre la
question de l'interdiction de mise en
location des passoirs thermiques sous
son absolument et donc du coup c'est une
oui absolument et c'est une mesure qui
était absolument juste parce qu'elle
répondait justement à la crise des
gilets jaunes il faut se rappeler c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a fait mais la loi doit
s'adapter aussi à la société est-ce que
elle vous semble toujours pertinente
absolument rythme pour en finir avec les
pass Therm si on ve fonctionner
correctement avec la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments et je rappelle
que je porte un un rapport parlementaire
qui est transpartisan qui répond mot
pour mot au rapport parlementaire qui a
été fait au Sénat qui est transpartisan
et qui dit exactement la même chose que
le notre alors qu'est-ce que vous faites
le calendrier aujourd'hui il est clair
et il permet de savoir quel est
l'échéancier que vous avez montré dans
le AB CD EFG aujourd'hui l'objectif en
2050 c'est d'attindre A ou B la moyenne
qu'on se fixe et on se le fixe pas dans
le théorique on se le fixe parce que
sinon on sait pas boucler notre équation
énergétique française on peut pas faire
l'impasse de l'équation énergétique
française RTE nous dit on ne sait pas
boucler si on n pas un niveau
extrêmement important de rénovation
énergétique notamment dans les passeoirs
thermiques parce que c'est là qu'on
consomme le plus par on Fa rien sur
cette ition climti énergétique c'est FO
TR les les ches énergétiques pour les
ménlages donc non ce que je veux dire
c'est que clairement le calendrier on
peut pas y toucher mais on peut toucher
plein d'autres choses pour faire en
sorte qu'on puisse arriver à faire euh
les les choses dans les temps déjà il
faut se rappeler que l'obligation dont
on parle c'est pas une obligation qui va
mettre euh les ménages à la rue du jour
au lendemain ça n'est pas vrai ce qu'on
a voté à l'Assemblée nationale en 2019
donc il y a quand même un certain nombre
d'années maintenant hein donc on a eu
quand même quelques années pour se
retourner pour savoir de quoi il parlait
là on a l'impression que tout le monde
découvre enfin c'est pas tout à fait
juste une guerre en Ukraine entre les
deux enfin oui d'accord mais en l'UR la
crise covid a quand a quand même
complètement
bloqué pendant la crise covid pas pas au
même niveau pas au même niveau il était
au boulot quand même pas du tout au même
niveau et ensite Ren et là le bâtiment
va très mal mais on est bien d'accord
mais c'est deux sujet différents c'est
quand même deux sujets différents donc
il faut pas tout mélanger mais je suis
bien d'accord sur le fait qu'il y a une
crise bombe sociale du logement tout à
fait d'accord avec vous on est vraiment
dans une situation il faut qu'on arrive
à desserrer cette crise là vraiment et
il faut qu'on arrive à passer la bulle
parce que ce que je lisais aussi d'un
économiste encore cet après-midi c'est
que déjà d'une part cette crise là elle
est partout en Europe c'est pas un fait
français donc c'est pas lié
spécifiquement à la politique nationale
c'est un fait absolument donc ça il faut
quand même mesurer que dans tous les
autres pays sont dans la même situation
ensuite dans un deuxième moment il faut
aussi se rendre compte que je vous le
disais on n pas le choix de ne pas
atteindre ces objectifs là c'est bien
comprisalouche il y a des aides du
gouvernement qui sont sur la table on va
voir un reportage dans un instant sur
ces Français qui ont décidé de faire ce
choix là de la rénovation thermique avec
plus ou moins de difficultés elles sont
suffisantes comment ça fonctionne euh
elles ont été augmenté ces fameuses
primes Renov est-ce que oui elles ont
elles ont été augmenté mais si vous
voulez le problème il est pour moi
beaucoup plus vaste le tout le monde
devrait avoir un toit sous sous sous sa
tête tout le monde devrait pouvoir être
logé en France c'est inadmissible dans
un pays comme le nôtre on puisse pas se
loger c'est intolérable et effectivement
et les postures les les les les
communications et puis les plans à la
petite semaine qui change toutes les 2
minutes c'est suffit vous savez le monde
du logement euh le le les acteurs du
logement que nous sommes agents
immobiliers on voit les Français au
quotidien on voit la situation
aujourd'hui vous avez vous aurez déjà
vous avez déjà aujourd'hui une
interdiction des logements qui sont en
G+ c'est-à-dire qui consomment plus 450
kWh par mèt Carr par an qui sont
interdits à la location c'estàdire que
les propriétaires ils ne peuvent plus
trouver de nouveau locataires ça ça vous
semble absurde aujourd'hui c'est déjà en
vigueur je sais bien mais est-ce que ça
vous semble absurde regarde la demande
ça me semble absurde vous savez
l'absurdité c'est on doit tenir compte
de la situation tout ce qui est qui est
effectivement un bilan énergétique qui
soit favorable tout le monde est
d'accord là-dessus il y a pas de débat
le problème c'est la faisabilité c'est
l'accompagnement il faut que les gens
aent la capacité de faire ce qu'on leur
demande là à la fin de l'année janvier
2025 vous avez près de 700000 logements
qui seront plus au norme est-ce qu'on va
arriver à à mettre au norme 700000
logements d'ici à 2025 l' est là
reportage justement quels sont ces
propriétaires qui ont décidé de franchir
le pas comment sont-ils accompagnés
est-ce qu'ils ont les moyens ou
répercutent-il finalement le montant de
tous ces travaux sur leur futur
locataire reportage Léos
regardez chacun son appartement et
chacun sa galère Virginie vit ici dans
cette résidence construite en
1965 très vite elle décide d'isoler son
appartement là on a dû isoler
le mur donc en fait c'est c'est décalé
on se rend pas compte mais il y a des
plaques de plaqu au plâtre avec de
l'isolant à l'intérieur on a isolé le
sol en mettant en dessous du parquet une
mousse en fait isolante et puis la
dernière grosse étape ça a été quand
même les
fenêtres et malgré tous ses travaux son
appartement n'est pas si bien isolé la
faute à son immeuble ce qu'il faudrait
c'est que au niveau de la copropriété
tout le toit de l'immeuble en fait soit
isolé pour qu'on gagne vraiment en
je peux pas faire ça toute seule en fait
il faut que l'ensemble des
copropriétaires vote la résolution àager
à 700 km de Virginie dans le Nord aussi
l'inquiétude du mauvais bilan
énergétique monte le propriétaire de
cette maison a décidé lui de faire appel
à un expert j'arrive à bouger à la main
et on sent l'air froid ici qui pénètre
auparavant le particulier avait un
besoin plus au niveau du confort
thermique et en deuxè au niveau économie
d'énergie là je dirais ça c'est inversé
verdict pour ce propriétaire dans un
mois un bilan énergie que Jean-Luc lui
en région parisienne reçoit tout juste
pour son studio de 21 m² le diagnostic
fait que vous êtes g à 493 kmh pour
décrocher une meilleure note Jean-Luc va
devoir isoler ses murs objectif visé la
note e coût des travaux 2000 € quand je
revendrai le le bien à un moment donné
bah sera conforme au marché donc il y
aura pas de
décotte notre tour de France des
propriétaires en détresse continue
direction chez
Marcell ce retraité fait visiter son
appartement à une association de
propriétaires Alexis ben je te présente
mon T2 un appartement classé e en
1991 aujourd'hui classé g Marcel veut
rapidement le vendre on a de la pierre
de qualité depuis 30 ans elle n'a pas
bougé je n'ai pas besoin de ravalement
ici donc les ation ne peut se faire que
par les les murs intérieurs les petits
retraités c'est un désastre pour eux ils
ont plus de compléments de revenu et en
réalité faire un investissement aussi
lourd en terme de travaux pour un petit
logement c'est peut sur 10 ans et en
10ant il s'y retrouve pas du tout pour
ses propriétaires comme pour les 5200000
autres logements aujourd'hui considéré
comme passoir thermique le compte
Harbour est lancé en 2025 les log classé
g seront interdit à la location en 2028
ce seront ceux classé
F Marjoline mier milfer la grande
question pour ces propriétaires on
parlera des locataires derrière mais
c'est c'est au fond les moyens
l'accompagnement on voit bien que pour
certains c'est exorbitant que fait le
gouvernement à quelle hauteur mon j'ai
10000 € à avancer pour cette rénovation
thermique combien est prise en charge
par le gouvernement par les aides de
l'État sur le budget alors la question
c'est de quel travaux parlez donc on
peut pas dire ça de cette façonlà par
contre ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que d'un point de vue budgétaire en 2017
on était à 1,7 milliard d'euros sur le
cite c'était le la méthode auparavant de
d'accompagnement des des travaux on est
à 5 milliards sur ce PLF mais en
pourcentage moy une multiplication très
importante des moyens qui sont engagés
sur plus d'argent en enveloppe
budgétaire mais par foyer on a des à peu
près des alors on a une multiplication
par enfin vraiment conséquente des
budgets de l'an je l'ai dit et par 10
des ménages accompagnés on est passé de
je pas dire deise ce que je dis de
mémoire de
70000 ménages accompagnés à 700000
ménages accompagnés doncme c'est si lent
on voit bien que le rythme oui de
basculement vers les rénovation est est
très lent on l'a vu dans dans la
présentation beaucoup qui arrivent à se
faire et le rythme il est de plus en
plus rapide et chaque année on en en
plus donc c'est quand même intéressant
en ensuite ce que je trouve intéressant
dans votre reportage c'est que la
personne qui était dans ses dans ses
travaux elle a fait un certain nombre de
travaux qu'elle pouvait faire toute seul
sans avoir à passer par sa copropriété
elle les a fait vous dites qu' elle est
pas forcément suffisamment isolée enfin
pas vous m' vous avez dit pas si bien
isolé que ça mais en tout cas elle est
sans doute plus en FG donc elle est déjà
plus concernée par l'interdiction ça
veut dire qu'on peut faire des choses
déjà à son niveau et à l'échelle de son
appartement pour pouvoir être en
conformité par ailleurs le studio g
c'est exactement la même chose il a pu
mettre de € et il est sorti de la
passoire termique sur les diagnostics
tout ça est très transparent quel que
soient les
superficies on peut se dire qu'on a
quelques chose qui est juste quel que
soient les les appartements alors tout
ça est des fois parfois il y a des il y
a des erreurs sur les diagnostics parce
que les diagnostiqueurs sont des êtres
humains et parfois ils se trompent et
puis il y a des il y a des difficultés
effectivement de de de de voilà des
difficultés qui qui qui qui relève d'un
diagnostiqueur à un autre des fois on a
des différences par contre il y a une
obligation effectivement d'afficher le
diagnostic euh mais le le problème le
problème les aides effectivement sont
conséquentes les aides ont été
augmentées c'est pas le problème si je
peux me permettre le problème c'est
est-ce qu'ils sont suffisants pour que
la mesure qui a été décidée soit
appliquée et soit supportable par les
gens le problème il est là parce que
vous avez tout un tas de choses derrière
avec la avec la location qu'est-ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui un propriétaire qui
a un bien en location c'est que il est
dans l'alternative soit de faire les
travaux soit pas pouvoir louer son bien
et donc qu'est-ce qu'il choisit très
souvent pas faire les travaux oui c'est
son logement c'est son logement parce
que on oublie les locataires qui sont
qui sont dans des passoirs termiques C
on s'en occupe absolument pas ils nont
absolument rien pour eux on les aide pas
du toutup on va dire au proprio toi tu
fais la réhabilitation si tu veux vendre
ou si tu si tu as ton logement vacant
mais en attendant si tu as ton locataire
en place juste tu peux pas augmenter le
loyer de 3 et5i % du montant de
l'inflation déjà une cont non non
attendez attendez le locataire lui lui
il paye c'est lui qui chauffe et c'est
lui qui paye
donc là de ce point de vue-l il y a rien
du tout la deuxième chose si l'échec
énergie il y a des accompagnements quand
même pour essayer d'accompagner les
ménages qui sontord bon alors passoir
passoir thermique ok les logements frigo
les G plus excusez-moi mais c'est des
logements frigo peut pas les appeler que
rien n' été fait ouais bon mais en
attendant pour ces locataires là ceux
qui vivent dans les les vrais passepirs
thermiques ceuxl il y a vraiment pas
grand-chose et il continue à se cailler
et il continue à là c'est beaucoup plus
large à crever de chauduss en été parce
que là il y a aussi ce problèmelà euh
n'est pas abordé dans votre rapport
cette question réellement c'est-à-dire
que euh on va dire les logements euh euh
les logements fournaises les logements
fournaises on pourrait les appeler comme
ça et bien ces logements-là ils sont euh
on s'en occupe très peu euh on sait très
bien que aujourd'hui il faudrait
produire des logements avec une
ventilation deux avec deux de deux
expositions les pays du Sud font tout ça
contre la chaleur et ben on fait de la
ventilation
c'est vraiment un principe de base de
l'architecture en FR on produit des
logements monorientés c'està-dire des
logement plein sud les gens ils se
prennent les habitants ils se prennent
le soleil en pleine tête et donc souvent
d'ailleurs il y a pas de volet c'est pas
obligatoire les volets sont pas
obligatoire bien compris vous vouliez
dire aussi que vous craignez que pour
ceux qui font les travaux les
propriétaires ne répercutent le prix des
travaux sur les loyers ça vous le voyez
ça déjà sur le terrain bah écoutez toute
façon c'est bien chose
si un bailleur parce que il faut dire
les choses aussi Marcel là qui est dont
on parlait est-ce qu'il est propriétaire
occupant propriétaire bailleur voyez il
faut quand même arriver à faire la
distinction c'est pas les mêmes
situations bon et donc pour nous le le
le propriétaire bailleur s'il arrive à
libérer son logement c'est il dégage son
son locataire il va faire des travaux il
va le relou plus cher bien sûr donc tout
ça ça va faire augmenter les loyers pour
nous il faudrait aller dans l'autre sens
c'est-à-dire qu'il faudrait baisser les
loyers des locataires qui sont dans des
passards thermiques pour obliger les
bailleurs les encourager à faire les
travaux et il faudrait geler parce que
on est dans des niveaux de loyer qui
sont aujourd'hui de plus en plus
inaccessibles pour les pour les pour les
candidats locataires les
jeunes les les travailleurs de première
ligne les les ouais bah ouais tous ceux
tous ceux dont on a besoin là pour
isoler justement par exemple ceuxl et
bien on les alors là vous posez des
questions aussi des moyens comment on
finance çaouche puis pieren on a ça
parce que ce que j'entends fait un petit
peu bondir vous savez il est fini le
temps il est fini le temps où on pensait
et que effectivement les propriétaires
c'est ceux qui se gavaient au détriment
des locataires ce qui abusaient du
locataire vous avez effectivement des
cas comme ça mais aujourd'hui c'est pas
le cas vous avez beaucoup de
propriétaires qui renoncent à faire les
travaux et qui vendent leur logement du
coup il y a moins de logements
disponibles donc ce qui a pour effet de
faire monter les une transaction alors
faut savoir hein il y a beaucoup de
propriétaires ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup de propriétaire renonce à
faire les travaux contenu du coût malgré
les aides vous avez des coûts qui sont
extrêmement importants et effectivement
des fois vous avez même pas
l'assurance en classe énergétique dans
dans le temp alors comment comment on
fait pour dstesser le marché locatif
parce que c'est ça la la crainte d'dard
Philippe en adéquation il il le dit
attention aujourd'hui à part hériter
c'est plus possible de se loger aussi
bien évidemment à l'achat mais aussi à
la location si on touche à ces
impératifs climatiques qu'est-ce qu'on
fait pierre hray du monde B c'est c'est
la question la réalité c'est qu'on a
d'une part une production de logement
qui est de plus en plus chè parce que le
coût des matériaux a augmenté on a une
pénuriine mainduvre ça a été dit dans
dans le premier reportage et on a de
moins en moins de terrain constructible
et le terrain constructible à cause du
Zéro artificialisation nette et
généralement du terrain constructible
qui est sur des friches et où ça coûte
donc du coup beaucoup plus cher parce
qu'il faut des pollué il faut enlever le
matériel les matériaux qui sont présents
détruire dans certains cas et rebâtir
derrière alors justement transition
parfaite je vais vous montrer ce qu' a
dit et c'est pas passé il naperçu
Laurent voquier à l'association des des
mares ruraux il a qualifié la loi climat
et résilience de ruralcde si on peut
voir s'afficher le verbatime de le
renvoquer bientôt peut-être alors
j'essayie de le
retrouver ça y est je l'ai donc mettre
sous cloche les descis des permis de
construire sur la ruralité cela signifie
qu'on s'interdit toute forme d'avenir le
président de la région au vergonab qui a
décideré en consultation manifestement
avec les départements de ne pas
appliquer la loi il est hors la loi vous
condamnez ça ou pas non je sais pas s'il
a le droit en réalité je ça je crois pas
qu'il a le droit ça c'est
sûr non mais non mais c'est un point
c'est un point qui est extrêmement
central pardon mais zéro
artificialisation nette ça veut dire que
normalement on ne peut pas bâtir sur des
terrains qui sont sont pas déjà bâtis
moi je pose une question exemple très
concret dans ma circonscription on a
adinkererc à quelques 5 ou 10 km de ma
circonscription les la Grande Vallée de
batterie qui va s'installer parce qu'on
doit enlever les moteurs thermiques des
véhicules pour transformer en véhicules
électrique très bien centrale nucléaire
de Graveline l'ensemble des usines de
batteries on a 15000 emplois qui vont
arriver on ne peut pas bâtir ailleurs
aujourd'hui les logement il y a plus de
friche industrielle très très peu et
aujourd'hui avec le zéro artif alisation
nette on ne saura pas loger les 15000
personnes qui viennent travailler
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qu'on fait
qu'est-ce on fait est-ce qu'on fait le
choix de ne pas bâtir est-ce qu'on fait
le choix de laisser comme c'est le cas
actuellement des gens dormir dans des
bangalo dans des campings ou dans des
mobilehom dans des campings est-ce que
c'est ce choix qu'on fait 2050 d'arriver
au zéro
artificialisation la réité mais vous
rigolez mais la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est que les autorités préfectorales
anticipe en dehors des cadres de la loi
et disent non non parce que il y a la
loi zé artificialisation nette et donc
du coup même même si la loi n'est pas en
vigueur aujourd'hui nous faisons en
sorte qu'il n'y ait plus aucun terrain
qui soit constructible et donc pardon
mais la réalité c'est que on ne pourra
pas concrètement c'est un cas
extrêmement clair que je mets sur la
table assurer les 15000 travailleurs qui
qui viendront pour faire en sorte de
décarboner l'industrie automobile et les
logés en même temps ça n'arrivera pas
c'est c'est un cas de figure intéressant
parce mais c'est super intéressant une
usine pour décarboner les batteries
électriques qui peut pas être construite
à cause du c'est juste circonscription
pardon ou alors sur votre
circonscription parce que j'ai fait mes
recherches en terme de seuil de pauvreté
vous êtes à 20 % de personnes sous le
seuil de pauvté contre 14,5 % en France
vous avez 8 % de logement vacant et vous
avez une mobilité locative de 15 % par
an donc j'ai fait quand même mes
recherches y compris sur votre
circonscription pour savoir de quoi on
parlait de manière claire et
effectivement moi je me demande ce que
vous dites à vos concitoyens qui sont
sous le seuil de pauvreté qui sont
probablement en location dans les
passeports thermiques et à qui vous
dites que on s'en fiche de savoir com
ils vont payer
je vais vous dire franchement ce que et
je vais vous répéter ce que je leur ai
dit je leur ai dit que à cause du Zéro
artificialisation nette à cause des
normes environnementales qui ont été
mises on m'empêche dans la commune dont
j'étais maire à marconcalisi de 11000
habitants alors qu'on est en dotation de
solidarité urbaine et qu'on n'est pas au
20 % de logements sociaux on m'indit de
construire des logements sociaux allez
vous répondez là sur le sur le la lutte
contre le
béton c'est la fin de ce débat donc vous
répondez là-dessus pu on va en reparler
de toute façon cette question là ça va
monter c'est S
alleyème sera leot de
la on m on m'a interdit de faire du
logement social madame la députée pour
terminer mais ça c'est très curieux il
faudra qu'on regarde le dossier ensemble
je vous propose qu'on le regarde
ensemble puisque la loi
sur non mais je veux bien qu'on en
discute
ensembleoutir sur des sur des visions
comm ce que je dis c'est que sur le Zen
20030 division par 2 du rythme
d'artificialisation on n pas en train de
geler les territoires à l'heure actuelle
on est en train de dire qu'on divise par
deux le rythme c'est qu'à partir ce que
soit 2è phase 2030 2050 qu'on sera
effectivement dans un situation où on
sera en équilibre total où on dira pour
pouvoir construire du neuf il faudra
desés
artificialisés que vous pouvez il faut
la construire dans c'est dans C ans
pardon mais 2030 c'est dans 7 ans c'est
dire qu' aujourd'hui SCOT l'ensemble des
documents d'urbanisme commence à prendre
comp je sens voilà on vous réinvitera
pour un débat sur les anes c'était une
ouverture en fin de sujet mais peut-être
c'était un peu risqué
parce qu'en fait on se rend bien compte
que les territoires ils ont besoin de
solution spposer au transitions
environmental c'est pas dans l'intért
merci d'être venu débattre en direct sur
LCP chacun son message c'est
finizz c'est fini parce que j'aimerais
qu'on parle un petit peu du film à venir
merci à vous dans une dizaine de minutes
vous restez avec moi Nicolas Miletic les
parties prix de nos affranchis ce soir
le billet politique de yelg sur la
révision un peu déceptive d'Emmanuel
Macron de la Constitution le regard de
Richard verli sur l'impuissance de
l'Europe sur la crise arménienne et puis
dans Bourbon Express quel est le menu ce
soir Stéphanie des pierre comment
redonner du peps aux questions au
gouvernement du mardi et ben on va voir
ça tout à l'heure à tout à l'heure les
amis mais d'abord on y va on va se
plonger dans l'histoire d'un des livres
les plus importants du 20e siècle
L'Archipel du Goulag d'Alexandre
solgenitzin c'est un immense récit trois
tomes qui révèlent au monde entier le
système concentrationnaire euh de
l'Union soviétique votre film Nikolas
Miletic raconte les conditions de son
écriture de sa publication de sa
diffusion et vous allez le voir c'est
digne d'un roman de John leCarré
l'invitation est signée Marco Pomier on
en parle tous les deux juste
après si on vous invite Nikolas Miletic
c'est pour nous parler d'un livre majeur
l'un des plus marquants du 20e siècle
L'Archipel du Goulag dans ce
documentaire réalisé par Jean crépu vous
retracez la genèse de ce manuscrit
objet de toutes les polémiques son
auteur Alexandre solgitsin y raconte la
tyrannie des camps de travail dans
l'URSS de Staline un tsunami de violence
de témoignage et de vérité quand on lit
le livre les trois tomes on est
excusez-moi on pass un roule le
compresseur quoi années 70 le manuscrit
écrit dans le plus grand des secrets
circule clandestinement dans une Russie
fermée à double tour surve par un KGB
tout-puissant les arrestations et
condamnations sont nombreuses pour ceux
qui osent reproduire et diffuser le
livre immense succès en Occident
véritable choc idéologique et politique
une parution qui dérange aussi au partis
communistes français notamment beaucoup
de gens ne voulaient rien savoir le
sujet les mettait mal à l'aise pour de
nombreuses raisons bonne ou mauvaise
parce que l'Union soviétique avait été
notre allié pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et qu'il était gênant de dire
que nous avions détruit un monstre avec
l'aide d'un autre la répression
politique en Russie vous l'avez observé
de près Nicola Miletic vous l'ancien
correspondant et directeur de l'AFP à
Moscou expulsé du pays en 1981 pour vos
relations avec des dissidents auteur
réalisateur dans votre premier film sur
L'Archipel du Goulag il y a 16 ans
Alexandre soogénitine témoigne en
personne sur l'épopée de son œuvre son
ultime entretien l'archipel est venu à
moi à travers ses gens bien sûr il ne
comprenaient pas ce que je faisais
pourquoi j'avais besoin d'eux personne
n'était au courant de mon projet
personne aujourd'hui Nicolas MTIC vous
donner la parole aux invisibles à ceux
qui n'ont rien oublier de ce passé
terrifiant souvent occulté par les
Russes alors ce soir on a une question
pour vous dans la Russie autocratique de
2023 peut-on lire librement L'Archipel
du
Goulag
réponse la réponse est pour l'instant
oui
euh je ne sais pas jusqu'à quand parce
que tout ce dont parle
l'archipel est en train peu à peu de
disparaître
c'est-à-dire l'organisation mémoriale
qui s'occupait justement de de
poursuivre le travail fait dans
l'archipel c'est-à-dire euh étudier
documenter garder la mémoire de toutes
ces cette période de de de terreur
salinienne cette organisation a été a
été liquidé
euh à quelques jours après avoir reçu le
prix Nobel euh tout à fait et de plus en
plus il y a des des témoignages visuels
de la terreur stalinienne qui
disparaissent par exemple des des
monuments euh à des victimes de la
répression qui sont dans des régions que
ce soit dans l'Oural ou du côté de
Saint-Pétersbourg et qui sont enlevés
tout simplement qui disparaissent donc
les témoignages visibles ouais on va
revenir justement sur la Russie de
Poutine d'aujourd'hui et son rapport sa
nostalgie appuyée pour pour l'exunion
soviétique votre film c'est en quelque
sorte la suite de l'histoire secrète de
L'Archipel du Goulag qui était un film
événement en 2008 on y retrouve donc ces
invisibles ces détenus du Goulag qui ont
aidé ce génit cine dans son travail vous
raconterz aussi la réception du livre
dans les années 70 et c'est passionnant
de voir qui ouvre les yeux qui a du mal
à les ouvrir et surtout vous reprenez
des extraits de ce dernier entretien que
vous a accordé avec jean- crépu
Alexandre
chogenidcine racontez-nous dans quelles
circonstances ça s'est passé comment
vous l'avez rencontré
précisément en fait c'est CIT évidemment
un peu
compliqué à l'époque de le de le voir
parce qu'il était déjà une santé assez
ébranlée euh mais j'avais bon un petit
avantage c'est que j'avais euh quand
j'étais jeune correspondant de l'Agence
France Presse à Moscou euh je je
j'aidais le fond d'aide au prisonnier
politique qui existait grâce à l'argent
de la vente de au droit d'auteur de
l'archipel du goulac donc j'avais
certains contact avec avec Alexandre
solgénicine et sa femme et donc ça m'a
permis de ça m'a permis de voilà d'avoir
ce contact et de d'aller l'interviewer
et et il revient justement sur les les
étapes et les circonstances euh de la
publication de ce livre édifiant euh il
a traversé le rideau de fer dans des
conditions absolument incroyables ce
livre il a d'abord été transformé en
microfilm oui euh parce queévidemment
c'est très volumineux
donc c'était toujours le problème quand
il y avait des choses à faire passer
d'Union soviétique vers l'Occident
comment faire donc il fallait en général
que ça passe par la valise diplomatique
ou par des diplomates mais si c'était
quelque chose de très gros comme le
manuscrit de l'archipel très compliqué
donc beaucoup plus simple d'en faire un
microfilm et ça c'est beaucoup plus
facile à cacher le manuscrit arrive en
France en 1968 ce sont deux éditeurs
français évidemment ils le lisent c'est
que c'est Claude Durand et Nikita Struve
qui décide de le publier c'est une
évidemment c'est une bombe pourquoi la
France pourquoi il arrive en France ce
pays là particulier alors il arrive en
France parce que
il y avait déjà un contact secret établi
entre sol genicine et Nikita Struve qui
était le responsable d'une maison
d'édition de l'émigration russe à Paris
imkapress qui existe
toujours à Paris donc et et s gine
manifestement avait suffisamment
confiance pour envoyer ce ce texte
auquel il tenait à ce moment-là sans
doute en priorité et les deux éditeurs
vont décideré de publier bien sûr mais
d'abord de travailler a une traduction
sauf que solicine qui est encore
évidemment en URSS euh le manuscrit va
tomber dans les mains du KGB et là tout
s'accélère il faut aller très vite oui
c'estd qu'une personne qui avait une de
ses invisibles c'est-à-dire des ces
personne qui dans la plus grande
discrétion
l'aidait ceici lui avait dit détruisez
cette copie puisquil y en a une nouvelle
remagé et cette personne était tellement
attachée à ce livre qu'elle avait pas
voulu le faire et elle en avait gardé
euh en dépit de l'ordre donné par
solgétin elle en avait gardé un
exemplaire etelleelle a été arrêtée par
le KGB et elle a elle a fini par par
dire où il était et voilà alors personne
ne sort indème de cette lecture c'est
très intéressant dans le film d'ailleurs
il y a plusieurs historiens qui disent à
la fois c'est un rouleau compresseur
parce que c'est un tableau global du
Goulag et du système concentrationnaire
il y a un historien ou un dissident qui
dit même c'est à la fois une analyse de
la terreur mais aussi sa mémoire et ça
c'est l'histoire orale grâce à tous ces
témoignages c'est plus de 200 de sec qui
qui lui parlent c'est ça aussi la force
de l'archipel
oui en effet euh pour la première fois
parce que c'était pas le le le premier
livre très loin de là qui parlait des
des camps soviétiques qui avait des
prisonniers français des prisonniers
russes des prisonniers d'autres
nationalités qui avaient donné leur
témoignage mais là c'était la première
fois qu'il y avait une vision globale
donc une analyse globale il y avait le
témoignage de l'ancien prisonnier solin
mais qui était considérablement enrichi
par les 227 sauf erreur témoignages qui
lui avaient été apportés par d'anciens
détenus et donc c'est une vision globale
assez polyphonique et tout ça écrit par
un très bon écrivain système
d'oppression massive comparable au
nazisme dans son caractère systématique
diriez-vous sans aucun doute qui a duré
beaucoup plus longtemps euh avec
euh avec un aspect euh qui
malheureusement le nazisme a été euh a
été vaincu et a disparu malheureusement
le le stalinisme on ne peut pas dire la
même chose il
ressurgit il ressurgit le stalinisme
ressurgit s la forme du poutinisme
aujourd'hui euh voilà c'est pas c'est
pas exactement la même chose il y a pas
une terreur de masse comme c'était le
cas sous mais moi qui ai vécu l'époque
de la répression sous bregenief le cette
époque que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
sous Poutine est infiniment plus
répressive à l'époque des des opposants
ne prenaient pas 25 ans de camp comme
Vladimir caramourza qui a pris ça il y a
quelques mois o naavalni 18 ans h on
peut être arrêté pour une vidéo repostée
sur les réseaux sociaux une chanson
chantée dans dans un bar les prisons
sont remplies de de mineur également
vous faites le vous faites le parallèle
vous pensez qu'il sera jugé un jour
Vladimir Poutine pour ses crimes de
guerre ces exactions non non je ne pense
pas je ne pense pas et la société russe
que vous connaissez on parle beaucoup
d'une apathie d'un silence mais est-ce
qu' elle est aussi peut-être dans sa
partie la plus
jeune dans la dans la résistance d'une
certaine façon alors il faut bien
comprendre que si vous prenez C en
pour avoir reposté quelque chose sur
facebook TikTok ou ou d'autres réseaux
sociaux ça a une vertu pédagogique quand
même forte ça fait réfléchir beaucoup de
gens ça dissuade c'est sûr et ça
dissuade voilà donc ça peut expliquer ce
qu'on peut considérer comme une certaine
apathie vu d'ici quand on est quand on
est au chaud ceux qui sont vraiment les
plus opposés qui ne voulaient pas faire
la guerre en Ukraine ils ont voté avec
leurs pieds c'est-à-dire c'estes 100 100
150000 on ne sait pas personnes qui ont
fuit évidemment les plus
jeunes mais la résistance en tant que
telle l'opposition en tant que telle qui
se manifeste ça reste toujours vu les
conditions quand même extrêmement
sévères ça reste quelque chose de
marginal c'était le cas auparavant et ça
le reste aujourd'hui et elle est sous
les barreaux en la personne dealv et de
beaucoup d'autres aujourd'hui finalement
sol
génitine n'a pas été arrêté en Russie
parce que d'une certaine manière son
expulsion grâce à son livre un peu
protégé c'est un dissident est-ce
que il peut il peut considérer d'une
certaine façon
en nétant pas arrêté parce que très vite
le cremelin va va se rendre compte du
danger de ce livre pour lui c'est
l'expulsion est-ce que ce livre l'a
protégé d'une certaine façon ou pas du
tout au regard de ce qu'il a vécu non en
fait c'est à cause de ce livre qu'il a
été bien sûr qu'il a été expulsé euh il
savait que c'était un peu son vatou une
fois que ce livre paraissait c'était
cétait terminé der et pour revenir juste
sur la question qui a été posé au tout
début c'est si on peut encore le lire
aujourd'hui je pense que par contre ce
livre ne pourrait en aucun cas être
publié aujourd'hui s'il sortait
aujourd'hui parce que tout le récit de
la deuxème guerre mondiale sur les le le
le souhait d'indépendance des Ukrainiens
et tout ça va absolument à l'encontre du
discours officiel bien sûr merci merci
beaucoup vous restez avec moi Nicolas
miltic je signale d'ailleurs que votre
film donc co réalisé avec Jean crépu est
en compétition au Festival du film
politique de La Baule dont SCP est
partenaire et qui commence aujourd'hui
jusqu'au weekend prochain donc bonne
chance avant de le retrouver sur notre
antenne le 24 octobre prochain c'est
l'heure d'accueillir les parties pris de
nos affranchi vous allez pouvoir réagir
on les accueille tout de
suite bonsoir les affranchis YG de
France Inter chef du service politique
et Richard bonsoir Miriam du quotidien
suisse bli installez-vous on commence
comme chaque soir par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée c'est
vous qui nous l'a raconté Stéphanie
Despierre bonsoir à vous bonsoir et je
vous parle des questions au Gouvernement
de la vie générale c'est trop long ça
ronronne ça s'endor c'est chiant c'est
pas moi qui le dit c'est un ministre au
bout d'une heure c'est vrai que c'est la
grande désertion dans l'hémicycle alors
la présidente de l'Assemblée veut
changer tout ça elle a donc fait une
réunion au sommet hier matin avec tous
les présidents de groupe il allit
plusieurs pistes de réforme au menu
qu'est-ce qui est sorti et bien rien
pour le moment en revanche il y a des
idées qui ont été totalement écartées
tout le monde est d'accord pour dire que
c'est trop long mais aucun groupe ne
veut évidemment réduire le nombre de
questions qu'il a le droit de poser et
le son temps de parole aujourd'hui par
exemple chaque député a 2 minutes pour
formuler sa demande le ministre a 2
minutes pour répondre Renaissance
proposait de tout réduire à 1 minute 30
ça permettait quand même de gagner une
demi heure niet a répondu à l'opposition
alors finalement il y a une proposition
qui ne suscite pas de lever de bouclier
général c'est celle qui consiste à dire
qu'on va faire 1h32 questions au
gouvernement et 30 minutes uniquement
pour la premier ministre alors c'est une
idée venue à d'outre manche pour donner
de l'intensité au débat en Angleterre
chaque mercredi seul le ou la chef du
gouvernement répond au députés un
pingpong auquel la redoutable margarte
tcher excellait regardez cet extrait de
1990 à leur côté théâtre politique les
Anglais avaient une longueur d'avance
madame le Premier ministre nous dira
enfin qui va porter le chapeau
aujourd'hui pour cet imm F laissé par
vous les
[Musique]
conservateursu vous avez toujours été un
parle CZ pas de ce
vousaconz j'ador que ça se passe comme
ça dans notremicycle qu'est-ce qu'ils en
pens maonun jeu comme ça sans filet sans
connaître les questions àavance pour la
première ministreorsé la question
matinon et pour le moment pas de réponse
il faut dire qu'Élisabeth borne n'a pas
n'est pas margarette tcher elle n'est
déjà pas très à l'aise dans la formule
actuelle et on a posé la question au
députés ils ont des avis plutôt mitigés
une demi-heure uniquement question à la
première ministre est-ce que ce serait
une bonne chose j'ai peur que ça
instaure quelque chose à deux vitesses
les questions lambda et puis les
questions à la première ministre que
tout le monde voudra poser ou non enfin
moi la la formule actuelle me va comme
ça ça sera peut-être pour elle
l'occasion de nous répondre parce que
c'est vrai que la plupart de nos
questions sont adressées à la première
ministre et souvent elle dit oui je vais
laisser le sous-secrétaire d'État
répondre on pourrait aussi rêver autre
chose c'est que les questions ne soient
uniquement posées que par l'opposition
rêve encore plus improbable bah
improbable c'est sûr mais on sait très
bien que les questions au Gouvernement
de la part de la majorité c'est des
questions qui sont déjà écrites dont les
ministres connaissent déjà la réponse et
qui sont en général faites pour flatter
ou mettre en avant l'action du
gouvernement inutile de vous dire que
c'est un vœux pieux mais l'opposition a
aussi d'autres remèdes est-ce que vous
vous auriez une solution magique pour
faire en sorte que cette séance soit
plus intéressante pour tout le monde ah
bah moi je pense que pour qu'elle soit
plus intéressante il faut avoir des
réponses ce qui est inintéressant
possible c'est d'avoir peut-être des
ministres qui se lèvent avec leurs
fiches qui sont déjà toutes écrites et
toutes préparées parfois qui répondent à
côté des questions sur lesquelles on les
interroge si on remettait les choses
dans le bon sens et qu'on avait vraiment
des réponses aux
questions peut-être qu'on aurait pas
besoin d'accorder une demiheure complète
à Elisabeth borne parce qu'en réalité si
on lui accorde une demiheure complète
mais qu'elle ne nous répond toujours pas
je suis pas certain que les députés
resteront elliisabeth band devra-t-elle
se plier à ce face à faceace avec 577
députés et bien la réflexion ne fait que
commencer si Matignon n'est pas d'accord
on voit mal comment l'assemblée pourrait
imposer ces changements car Myriam la
seule obligation c'est la Constitution
rien que la
Constitution et elle impose une séance
de question gouvernement par semaine
mais sans définir les détails bon ben on
suit ça de de près hâte de voir borne en
toucheur on ver
Go votre partie pris révision de la
Constitution justement débat au
Parlement vous redoutez un tragique de
répétition ouais un petit peu déprimé
c'est pe-êt dû à ma position
d'observateur privilégié de la vie
politique j'avais envie qu'il se passe
quelque chose en cette rentrée j'étais
partant pour une saison 2 à condition
qu'on change un peu le scénario et les
personnages raté Gérard Larcher a été
réélu sur un plateau au Sénat et statut
quo des vice-présidents à l'Assemblée
alors hier j'ai cherché le le renouveau
de mon pensier chez les sages du Conseil
constitutionnel au-dessus des colonnes
de Buren où Laurent Fabius Emmanuel
Macron fêtaent les 65 ans de la
Constitution secret de sa longévité
justement le fait qu'elle soit
régulièrement rajeunie parce que révisé
24 lifting depuis 1958 mais rien depuis
15 ans or à l'Élysée on nous avait dit
que le président donnerait sa vision et
puis que il fallait s'attendre à quelque
chose alors pourquoi vous ressortez déçu
en fait il pouvait pas y avoir de
miracle c'est tout la Constitution c'est
pas un clavier sur lequel vous
improvisez pour changer une touche faut
l'accord de l'orchestre soit mais il a
dit le président extension du champ du
référendum intéressant ça il est revenu
sur les modalités du Rip le référendum
d'initiative partagé vous savez celui
qu'on qui peut venir d'en bas des
citoyens mais jamais mis en œuvre
tellement il faut de conditions pour
l'enclencher Emmanuel Macron a dit qu'il
voulait baisser les seuils de combien on
ne sait pas